in kandidaten frank-walter steinmeier
betritt den saal wieder mit gibson
applaus also die entscheidung scheint
gefallen zu sein
da bleibe ich jetzt mal dran wir
aufgreifen bereicherung der polizei oder
wieder mit dem ergebnis kommen frank
walter steinmeier geht auf sein blatt
wird jetzt warten auf das ergebnis der
bundespräsident bundestagspräsident wird
gleich die den saal betreten noch kommen
die mitarbeiter auch der zählkommission
und alle die da hinten geholfen haben
müssen jetzt wieder in den saal
alle fahrten berghof norbert lammert und
es ist trotzdem noch mal auch wenn die
kollegen ja schon mehrfach angesprochen
haben es ist eine vergleichweise gelöste
jahren nachgerade weitere
bundesversammlung könnte man sagen unter
anderem auch weil das ergebnis im
vorfeld klar warum und trotz der
eindringlichen romanen worte dass
bundestagspräsident und zu beginnen ja
das ist sicherlich richtig
ich hatte vielleicht ein bisschen mehr
aufwarten dass es für etwas frostiger
hier und auch zugehen könnte bei den
beginnenden wahlkampf aber das ist nicht
der fall ich glaube jeder risiko ist
dass ich heute ein besonderer tag eine
besondere versammlung und dann nutzt man
die fernseh interviews um sozusagen
wahlkampf ein wenig schon zu machen aber
ich glaube jeder von denen die hier
sitzen ist schon ein druck da will auch
für ältere kolleginnen und kollegen die
das schon häufiger mitgemacht haben
eine solche bundesversammlung ist was
besonderes da hinten kommt glaube ich
norbert lammert genau einen zettel dabei
kein vettel aber der liegt
wahrscheinlich schon vor ihm haben und
jetzt das ergebnis verkünden
meine damen und herren die unterbrochene
sitzung ist wieder eröffnet ich bedanke
mich bei den schriftführern und
schriftführern die mit einer natürlich
über jahre eingeübten präzision möglich
das ergebnis vermittelt haben
ergebnis des ersten wahlgangs zur wahl
des bundespräsidenten abgegebene stimmen
1253 ungültige stimmen schöpfenden
gültige stimmen 1239 enthalten haben
sich 103 mitglieder dieser
bundesversammlung sind entfallen auf dr
christoph butterwegge 128 stimmen
[Applaus]
auf albrecht glaser 42 stimmen
auch alexander volz 25 stimmen auf
engelberg sonneborn zehn stimmen
[Applaus]
offenkundig haben nicht alle die jetzt
klatschen ihn auch gewählt
[Applaus]
und auch dr frank walter steinmeier 931
stimmen
damit heißt der neue bundespräsident
frank walter steinmeier wir sehen jetzt
die gratulation von jochen gipp und nun
kommt angela merkel mit dem großen
blumenstrauß mit 74,3 prozent ist von
walter steinmeier der abgegebenen
stimmen glaube ich gewählt worden
das ist ein gutes ergebnis vw hofer
gratuliert hier
und nun kommt auch noch martin schulz
dazu ist um genau zu sein das fünftbeste
ergebnis dass ein genug präsident aktiv
herz bei einer wahl besser waren das am
bix ausgekramt nur in der reihenfolge
von oben theodor heuss richard von
weizsäcker der allerdings gleich zweimal
und joachim gauck mit 78,7 dabei in
seiner wahl unterliegt haben befand
walter steinmeier schon sehr sehr nah
dran um erst mal gefragt walter
steinmeier dann demnächst
meine damen und herren ich muss die
mitglieder der versammlung und auch den
kandidaten um einen kleinen augenblick
aufmerksamkeit bitten die teams war alle
aus den bekannt gegebenen
abstimmungsergebnisse die richtigen
schlussfolgerungen
aber erst wenn festgestellt wird dass er
die notwendige gesetzliche wert erreicht
hat und sich dann packte mich
entschließe die wahl auch anzunehmen ist
der vorgang an sich der jetzt voreilig
bereits zur übergabe von bookeen geführt
hat also ich stelle fest dass nach
artikel 54 absatz 6 des grundgesetzes
gewählt ist wer die stimmen der mehrheit
der mitglieder der bundesversammlung
erhält das heißt wer mindestens 6 131
stimmen auf sich vereinigt hat das ist
ganz offensichtlich der fall der
kandidat dr frank walter steinmeier hat
die erforderliche mehrheit der stimmen
erhalten ist damit zum bundespräsidenten
der bundesrepublik deutschland gewählt
wenn er meine frage ob er die wahl
annimmt nun hoffentlich positiv
beantwortet
darauf weist norbert lammert für nochmal
rein reformen gehalten werden
walter steinmeier hat die wahl
angenommen nicht meine zusage sagt gerne
sogar
wenn man das hier oben in der kabine
noch mitbekommen hat ihr seht also
weiter mit der gratulationscour man erst
mal in seinem leben ist frank walter
steinmeier die nummer 1
die nummer eins in einem politischen
abend und dann noch in höchsten
politischen amts diese pflanzen zu
vergeben hat 1000 treffer gümbel viele
freunde aus niedersachsen sind gekommen
und hier ja sigmar gabriel steht neben
von walter steinmeier der präsidentin
macher hier der regel befreie hoffmann
der junge mann arrangiert damen und
herren es gibt natürlich in
verständlichen wunsch fast aller
mitglieder der bundesversammlung dem
gerade gewählten bundespräsidenten
persönlich zu gratulieren
ich hab mal durchgerechnet wenn das pro
vorgang zehn sekunden dauert würden wir
etwa drei stunden bis zur beendigung der
bundesversammlung benötigen
deswegen schlage ich mal vor dass ich
jetzt im namen der gesamten
bundesversammlung herrn steinmeier
herzlich zu seiner wahl gratuliert
von daher mehr zugemacht hat
anschließend an dem empfang teilzunehmen
besteht da sich fast unbegrenzt die
möglichkeit erstens persönlich zu
gratulieren und ihm vor allen dingen
wichtige empfehlungen für die
wahrnehmung seines amtes mit auf den weg
zu geben
so herr steinmeier wenn wir mögen
erhalten die den tatort
herr präsident kehrte mitglieder der
bundesversammlung der geehrten
mitbewerber meine sehr verehrten damen
und herren ihr macht mir mut
die das zuruf einer jungen frau damals
vor zwei jahren das lange in mir nach
gehalten und ich möchte ihnen heute an
sie weitergeben von herzen danke ich
ihnen den mitgliedern dieser
bundesversammlung für die ermutigung mit
der sie mich heute auf den weg in das
höchste amt im staate senden ihre wahl
erfüllt mich mit großer freude und mein
großer respekt vor diesem amt er bleibt
mein respekt ist umso größer weil
joachim gauck geben saal ist ein
bundespräsident in diesem amt und ich
füge hinzu und unserem land gut getan
hat einzelgewinn der für die freiheit
riecht und ihr das glück der freiheit
mit jeder faser verkörpert ihnen
verwehrt präsident gilt mein und ich bin
ganz sicher unser aller dank
ich danke allen die mich gewählt haben
für das vertrauen und denen die mich
nicht nur das jetzt haben
dem gebe ich ein versprechen im gleichen
respekt vor allen demokratischen
parteien vor regierung und opposition in
respekt vor dem viel klang der stimmen
in unserer demokratie werde ich dafür
arbeiten auch ihr vertrauen zu gewinnen
weil ich weiß meine damen und herren wir
leben in stürmischen zeiten viele in
unserem land sind verunsichert
die welt das hat der ein oder andere
schon mal zu mir gehört scheint als in
fugen aber viele fragen auf was ist
eigentlich der kitt der kippe unsere
gesellschaft im kern zusammenhält und
vor allen dingen hält dieser kids auch
für die zukunft und andere fragen wenn
die welt unsicherer wird und wenn uns
ein land mit dieser welt so eng
verflochten ist
was bedeutet das für unsere sicherheit
für unsere zukunft auch diese sorgen
spüre ich in unserem land und meine
damen und herren ich nehme sie an
aber in meinem letzten jahren hat auch
minister habe ich auch etwas anderes
erfahren wie sich ihr macht mir mut das
war eine junge frau in tunesien die
diesen satz zu mir gesagt hat eine
aktive sind die sich in ihrer heimat für
demokratie und menschenrechte engagiert
und als er diesen satz sagte
dann meinte sie gar nicht mit und auch
nicht meine delegation
sondern ihr macht mir mut das heißt
unser land deutschland frage meint ihr
deutschen macht mir mut war die aussage
dieser meine damen und herren ist es
nicht erstaunlich ist es nicht
eigentlich wunderbar dass dieses
deutschland unser schwieriges vaterland
die gustav heinemann ist man andere ist
es mich unterlag der slums zu viel in
der welt ein anker der hoffnung geworden
wir machen anderen mut nicht weit alles
gut ist in unserem lande sondern weil
wir gezeigt haben dass es besser werden
kann
das ist nach vielen frieden werden kann
und nach teilung versöhnung und das nach
der raserei die ideologien so etwas
einkehren kann die politische vernunft
dass uns viele geglückte in unserem land
an all das erinnert uns dieser tag der
tag der bundesversammlung als theodor
heuss war der ersten bundesversammlung
stammt der räumten die menschen in
deutschland den schritt von krieg und
diktatur beiseite der bauten wie stein
um stein die bundesrepublik auf eine
demokratie die damals noch dem fundament
messen festen halt finden konnte und
meine damen und herren und wenn diese
fundaments anderswo wackelt dann müssen
wir umso fester zu diesem fundament
steht
als peter roman herzog vor der
bundesversammlung stellt er war die
deutsche wiedervereinigung noch jungen
der baby wir sind es auch noch durchs
land aber es gab auch ängste vor dieser
neuen zukunft doch die lockrufe der ag
von damals zündelten mit kranz
feindlichkeit und ressentiments die hat
unsere gesellschaft damals überwunden
und ich bin sicher das werden wir heute
als die hunde brauchen
das habe ich das geeinte deutschland
durch den einsatz auf dem balkan mit
schwierigen außenpolitischen
entscheidungen konfrontiert mit einer
neuen verantwortung in der welt die bis
heute noch weiter gewachsen ist und die
wir angenommen haben
meine damen und herren wir haben viele
miteinander gemeinsam und nicht immer
waren die zeiten einfach und der blick
auf die welt
insbesondere der auf europa der grund
auch heute ist eine schwere zeit aber
meine damen und herren
diese zeit ist unsere wir tragen die
verantwortung wenn wir anderen mut
machen wollen dann brauchen wir selber
reden wir brauchen den mut zu sagen das
ist auch was nicht jetzt
wir müssen den anspruch fakt und flüge
zu unterscheiden
diesen anspruch müssen uns ihr stellen
das vertrauen in die eigene urteilskraft
das ist das stolze privileg eines jeden
bürgers und sie ist voraussetzung für
jede demokratie
wir brauchen den mut einander zuzuhören
die bereitschaft das eigene interesse
mich absolut zu setzen
das ringen um lösungen in einer
demokratie nicht als schwäche zu
empfinden die realität nicht zu leugnen
sondern sie verbessern gewann
und wir brauchen den mut zu bewahren was
wir haben freiheit und demokratie in
einem vereinten europa
dieses fundament das wollen
das müssen wir miteinander verteidigen
es ist nicht unverwundbar
aber ich bin fest davon überzeugt es ist
daran gelegen nicht auf eine insel der
seligen
wir sind teil einer welt mit ihren
risiken und risiken gibt es auch bei uns
aber meine damen und herren kaum
irgendwo auf der welt gibt es mehr
chancen als bei uns und wer meine damen
und herren wer wenn nicht wir kann da
eigentlich guten mutes einbehalten
liebe landsleute lasst uns mutig sein
dann jedenfalls ist mir um die zukunft
nicht bange
herzlichen dank
[Applaus]